against the norwegian wolf both have
claws and fangs and big reputations but
they need confidence cunning strength
and an iron will to survive let the fur
fly
that's a perfect description and we have
started david do we see kloss already
yes we do we see that magnus carson he's
actually gone on to his opponent's home
turf um janna pontiacchi ever since he
was young ever since these guys were
rivals at a young age he's been playing
an opening called the grunfeld defense
as black look what i've got prepared for
you i know that i'm better than you even
on your territory love it
that's right and we saw that on the last
turn black brought his king um on the
right-hand side of the board he castled
that king he moved it across two squares
he swapped around the rook with it
that's i mean that's what we should
always do in the opening stage to keep
our king nice and safe what has he got
in store for me um yeah napoleon he
develops his knight towards the center
there very sensible move
um he's attacking one of white's pawns
in the center of the board and therefore
white also brings a knight towards the
center he also develops it just keeping
um his central horns nice and safe and
we see an advance in the center of the
board magnus carson pushing forward
lots of action here upon lots of pieces
being traded
bishops have left the board knights have
left the board um white's bishop that
has just zoomed up towards the black
king to capture an opponent's bishop an
enemy bishop plenty of choice
black's king has just recaptured this
bishop here um
two black pieces are under attack white
has a choice which one do you take
white has decided to take the bishop and
we see a knight in the center
lots and lots of action and magnus
carson has castled on the opposite side
to his opponent
yes and we know that that means david
that means a war is about to begin
gonna go crazy and start attacking we
love it yeah that's right so magnus
carson has a lot of experience in this
type of position before he here we see
he's pushed his bishop out to the edge
of the board bishops are very long long
range pieces so he's just keeping an eye
on a very nice long diagonal there with
that bishop napoli actually he's got his
head down he knows he's seen this
position before he studied it he acts
like this when he's trying to recall
what he's looked at before uh maybe he's
got some coaches who've told him what to
do in this position but it's just a
memory game he's trying to recall things
now like blitz out those moves to drop
those moves on the board and napoli
actually pushes his king back he
retreats his king one square very safe
move
but
maybe a bit of a slow one it shows that
he's not attacking he's reacting and one
more very quick move from magnus yeah
this is all preparation for magnus he
has been there
on the on the board in this position in
the morning to do with that central
night okay and he has moved the queen to
the oh and look at the bar it says this
is completely winning for magnus
crossland
i'm shocked magnus he's frowning i think
this is a blunder i think that might be
a blunder i'm trying to work out why
um
why napoli actually has played that move
so we see there um he's just shuffled
his queen across he's defending his
knight right now but maybe this knight
is trapped white can attack this knight
one more time he can push his pawn
forward
um attacking this knight maybe there's a
trick maybe he can move this knight and
there's another option for uh magnus
carson he can break the connection
between black's queen and black's knight
he can push his central pawn forward
maybe this is the move that napoli
actually has missed cutting the
coordination between his queen and
knight and suddenly i think white is
going to win a piece i think that knight
is doomed if the pawn captures the pawn
white can trap this knight now this
knight has no safe square
it's pretty much game over already wow
if magnus carlsen finds this idea
realized that he might have blundered
horribly okay he will now he will
no
i think he's slowly starting to realize
what he's done oh yes he realizes
oh no pony actually realizes he is
there's a loss for him in the first game
already already imagine magnus cross and
he's still in his homework probably he's
probably even studied this exact
position before and the palmy actually
he's just been caught unawares he's been
caught by surprise i think he's gonna
pause here just for a couple of minutes
okay he has played pawn takes pawn we
will see magnus carson's next move um
immediately his pawn has advanced
white's pawn has advanced to attack that
knight in the center of the board that
knight is trapped napoli actually he's
just going to find a way to try and
survive to just keep the game going as
long as possible to hope that magnus
carlsen either gets nervous or makes
another mouse slip i think that's the
only chance but napomiacci's face there
he looks disgusted he
yeah you can see it there he is uh
i think he's emotionally absorbed
himself of this game and that's it when
he looks back on this match i mean for
example if he gets knocked out tomorrow
he'll look back on this game and think
this is where it all went wrong
magnus carson actually not even
capturing that knight in the middle of
the board that night is still trapped it
has no safe squares just teasing him
exactly he's just rubbing it in he's
saying i'm not in a rush i'm just gonna
prove my pieces white brings a rook
towards the center he will capture that
knight when it suits him so much about
oh let's take this move first that's
right so black has nothing to do that
knight has no safe squares so he thinks
okay i might as well push my pawns
forward and we see black pushes upon on
the left there it's the same side as
white's king
kind of it's a dream now that black can
try and push those pawns forward open up
squares open up lines towards white's
king but it's going to be far far too
slow and we see
magnus casting he's just playing with
his food now he's just teasing him he
just shuffles his king across one square
he knows there's no rush
um now he finally captures that knight
in the center um black knight has
disappeared he gets a pawn for it i'm
white okay magnus carson he's not even
pausing to think he's pushed another
pawn forward attacking that black rook
now in the middle of the board
and we know magnus he you know oh
another move we'll take that first
that's right um if we just bring up the
boards now we can see that black is
trying to create threats he just has to
hope for a kind of a moment of madness
for magnus carson black is attacking the
white queen here it's just a one move
threat but white has so many options for
example the queen could jump forward and
it's been played
that is like the perfect attacking
square for a queen especially with
black's pawn formation on the right hand
side of the board just to look at it
it's right in the middle there so an
appointment really trying hard he has
pushed his left-most pawn of the board
and he's trying to indicate some kind of
aggressive intentions but at the end of
the day is just a pawn that is attacking
white's king white's just trying to keep
the king
his king shelter he's just trying to
keep it blocked um that left side of the
board white's king is just trying to
maintain as much safety as possible as
long as black's queen doesn't get into
the game as long as black's queen is
stuck
deep in his own camp um then white's
king isn't extremely safe premium member
on chess24 and we also have a tweet from
vidit who also is asking there is a
chance for me to play in the next event
of champions chess tour by voting me
back in if you're a chess 24 premium
member please do vote below and you know
he played some fantastic
chess especially at the end when he came
back and he is such a nice guy and i
love the nice guys so he's a great smile
so another pawn has left the board
magnus carlsen did win a pawn if we
bring the board up just to show the last
couple of moves very nice idea here by
magnus carson he did win a pawn in the
center it is teamwork the queen and rook
ganging up together
this was actually a sacrifice and we see
another sacrifice um black just shuffled
his queen across the board white has
dropped his dropped his bishop sorry um
in the center here look at this the
bishop is lining itself up with the
black king this is beautiful chess um
this bishop is actually giving itself up
it's sacrificing itself
it
always seems like the most fantastic
chess moves and the mo the moves are
most remembered are the ones that finish
with sacrifice the queen sacrifice or or
bobby fischer's pawn sacrifice or also
ended in a checkmate yeah that's right
that's uh that's another thing that
chess players i mean we hate to lose but
we hate getting checkmated and it has
finished magnus carlsen has
won the first semi-final game against
jan and pognatchi fantastic start for
the world champion yeah that's uh i mean
yeah no problem actually he's actually
almost smiling there he knows that that
was kind of an embarrassing game magnus
cast and just wiped him off the board
we're only on move 26 and black has had
to resign